hey guys Pete here I don't usually do
trailer breakdowns from mr. robot but I
was rewatching the 14 episode 7 earlier
today and it gave me an idea so this
will be a short video to be my mr. robot
season 2 episode 7 trailer breakdown in
preview and it will definitely contain
spoilers for everything that has
happened up to this point in the show
and will also include clues that we got
to a possible big reveal in episode 7
trailer starts out with Elliot who is
still trapped in the room are lone star
dumped him he is slumped against the
wall half laying on the ground and we
see what looks like a frustrated mr.
robot leaning against the opposite wall
Elliot says what are you so afraid will
happen if you tell me the truth mr.
robot pounds the ball then we see him
turned around saying fine I'll tell you
as I was thinking of what else they
could be talking about besides what
happened to tyro like was there another
event he wanted answers about drew my
attention back to the sick sitcom
sequence in the last episode because
that's the last place that we've seen
tyro more about that in a minute though
so here we're getting a tease that mr.
robot is finally going to tell Elliot
what happened in those three days that
he couldn't remember this is big for a
number of reasons which makes me wonder
if it will actually happen right now
with so many episodes left I mean this
is episode 7 so we still have a few to
go we cut to somewhere that is
presumably in the e Corp headquarters
but it's not a place I remember seeing
before it's got really high ceilings TV
monitors all the way around you know
where there's people working side by
side in this giant screen with the e
core logo at the one end I'm no clue
what the significance of this is other
than that it's related to ecore since it
has ecore bomb that big monitor so I'm
not going to speculate the next words we
hear or Dom saying your story fascinates
me she goes on to say what were you
doing on a restricted floor these two
statements might be cut together you
can't really tell if they were said in
the same sentence we see that angela is
sitting there the wheels inside her head
or turning but we don't hear a respond
if you think about it Angela story
inside a geek or is marginally
fascinating if the FBI was looking into
the employees backgrounds she was or is
involved in bringing a large class
action suit against ecor which started
out right at the same time that she took
the job there
that part is interesting but the
immediate issue Angela faces is that Don
though she was on that floor I don't
know for sure is it that because she saw
her heading down the steps and looked
into who she was and if that's how she
does know what else does she know like i
said in my episode 6 review i'm not sure
how Angela can get out of this but we're
gonna have to wait and see we get a
quick shot of Philip price who says
don't we all protect our secret evil
agendas while he's talking we get a
sequence of shots where we see Dom
looking at a monitor in the high ceiling
room from before with two other agents a
shot of Darlene and what I thought
looked like a bathroom when I first saw
it flash like maybe she was looking in a
mirror then I see there's like an
attendant off to the side there and he's
male so I don't know and a straight-on
shot of price while he's talking and
then the scene comes to an end with a
close-up of mr. robot as price says the
words evil agendas from there we see
Elliot forcibly seated at a term of a
bottle own star then we see mr. robot
holding him back in the basement room
while asking what is the last thing you
remember we see a shot of a fire and a
dumpster in the street with a spray
painted sign that says burn a bag of
trash for four dollars we see railing
and in a way that looks like he's
reminding Elliot that he's as master
while they're at his office and then we
see mr. robot again who says we were
going to be next we get a glimpse of
Elliot outside cut back to the basement
where he says I did it didn't I it ends
there and for all intents and purposes
gives us the impression that maybe
Elliot killed Tyrell when mr. robot says
we were going to be next it sounds like
a justification for doing something to
protect themselves when Elliot follows
up with I did it what's another
conclusion we're supposed to come up
with this doesn't mean that it happened
I mean obviously it's a teaser trailer
but I would be interested to hear in the
comments if any of you guys had
interpreted this in a different way so
that is what it is but what stood out to
me is the connection to L it to the
sitcom and Elliot's episodic amnesia mr.
robot told him they were in that dream
because he was trying to protect him
from the beating that he was taking when
he tried to look at the game boy or in
the rearview mirror he told him the same
thing he told him when he tried to ask
who was in the trunk and when he tried
to look inside the trunk I mean he
basically told him keep your
the road and you know don't worry about
it when getting and showed up the same
thing happened to him in the dream that
happened to him in real life in both
cases Gideon was an innocent guy just
doing his job and in both scenarios he
ends up dead well Elliot didn't kill
Gideon with his own hands and therefore
he you know wouldn't have to forget
about it his actions directly led to his
death it's something that he tries to
keep down if Elliot wouldn't have set
things in motion while working at
allsafe Gideon would still be alive I
mean there's really no doubt about that
ty burrell is tied up in the trunk he
tries to escape and then mr. robot beats
him bloody with a tire iron later
whenever he's you know making noise or
whatever so in real life we have hints
that he is keeping in contact with
Joanna and Elliot actually at least
thinks he talked to him on the phone but
none of that is concrete so something's
off here we are meant to think at the
end of the trailer that it's likely that
Elliot killed tyrell during the three
days after the hat and that is why you
can't remember them on the other hand we
have Joanna storyline where it seems
like Tyrell is still nearby this 23
second clipped it definitely did brings
up more questions than it answers I mean
I really can't say i have come to any
solid conclusions but i do know that i
can't wait to see the next episode so
what do you guys think were there any
clues in the sitcom scene and did mr.
robot actually kill tyrell while he was
still in that trunk if Tyrell is dead
how would Elliot be tricking Joanna into
thinking is still alive all the time
while he was just still at his mom's
house personally I lean towards tyrell
still being alive but the trailer seems
to contradict it so like I said there's
way more questions than answers here
anyways let me know if you have any
other ideas or any questions in the
comments please like the video if you
found that interesting and subscribe to
my channel i'll be posting my episode 7
recap and review on thursday thanks for
watching i'll talk to you soon